what a weekend maybe one of the weekends
with the most explosive political news
in a very long time we're going to talk
about the Donald Trump leaked audio we
are going to talk about the second
presidential debate we are going to talk
about the WikiLeaks leaked Hillary
Clinton emails all in due time we have a
very very busy show today if you did not
pay any attention to the news over the
Columbus Day weekend an audio tape in
which Donald Trump is having a
conversation with TV host Billy Bush has
leaked this is from 2005 in it Trump is
heard using everything from sexually
aggressive to lewd language including
comments that sound like he's talking
about doing what he wants to women
sexually regardless of what it is that
they want based on his celebrity status
let's listen to just a little bit of the
tape take a look
maybe it's a different one yeah that's
it with a girl I'm gonna use subject X
just in case they start kissing her
you know I'm automatically attracted to
beautiful I just start pushing them it's
like a [ __ ] yeah I'm not gonna play all
three minutes I do want to tread
carefully for our affiliate stations and
the FCC restrictions that they have
fortunately no restrictions on cringe
because if so this video would not be
allowed anywhere
Trump hitting on married women while
married to Melania Trump here is Donald
Trump's apology / explanation that was
released I think just hours after this
video broke we will put it up on the
screen for you this was locker room
banter a private conversation that took
place many years ago Bill Clinton has
said far worse to me on the golf course
not even close I apologize if anyone was
offended apologizing if anyone was
offended is not the same as actually
just apologizing most importantly
however Bill Clinton is not running for
president of the United States even
better is Melania Trump statement about
this we'll put up a quote from Melania
Trump who on Saturday said quote the
words my husband used are unacceptable
and offensive to me this does not
represent the man I know he has the
heart and mind of a leader I hope people
will accept his apology as I have and
focus on the important issues facing our
nation and the world
funny how everyone should accept
milania's choice to stay with Donald
Trump respect that and focus on the
issues but everybody should ignore
Hillary Clinton's decision to stay with
Bill Clinton and keep talking about that
funny how the double standards just
constantly pop up now Nate Silver
predicts that Donald Trump's leaked
audio scandal will be the root cause of
his eventual downfall here is a quote
from Nate silver from 538 saying even
before the hot mic tape our model gave
Clinton a 5 to 6 percentage point lead
and the error in the forecast is love
roughly symmetric the polls could move
by 5 or 6 points
towards Trump giving him an arrow win or
equally likely per our model they could
move by five or six points towards
Clinton giving her a double-digit margin
to put it another way a Clinton
landslide is no more far-fetched than a
trump victory and given the events of
the past 24 hours probably less so more
on that later stay tuned for more about
this polling issue this may not be the
end of the leaked audio tapes The
Apprentice reality show producer bill
Pruitt tweeted after this recording
leaked that there are way worse
recordings to leak saying quote as a
producer on seasons 1 & 2 of The
Apprentice I assure you when it comes to
the Trump tapes there are far worse just
the beginning Pruett is not the first to
suggest that there will be more
revelations Fox News's at Henry top
according to a report by Fox News's at
Henry top trump adviser Ben Carson
suggested there would be more bombshells
to come a tweet which says bet real ben
Carson told me he and real Donald Trump
talked about more revelations coming
they have more things and they will drip
them out it's going to be an interesting
few weeks and I want to propose one
question to all Republicans who are now
confused about what to do about Donald
Trump here and they were all behind
Donald Trump during the primary imagine
how well Jeb Bush would be doing right
now against Hillary Clinton an
objectively unpopular politician there
can't be Republicans who still think
that they're better off with Trump than
Jeb Bush or basically any other
Republican right well actually there are
many